sehr geehrte frau bürgermeisterin liebe
preiser marian sehr geehrter herr
landrat lieber herr lamers lieber armin
laschet r ministerpräsident ich kann nur
so laut sprechen wie es die technik
hergibt und deshalb gebe ich mir alle
mühe aber es kann nicht lauter werden
ich möchte mich erst einmal bedanken
dass wir hier bei ihnen sein konnten
obwohl sie ja diese riesen probleme
haben und wir haben uns ja heute ein
bild machen können von den schäden die
es in bad münstereifel gibt und die sind
erschreckend menschen gesehen die alles
verloren haben und eine stadt die so
einzigartig konzipiert war wir diese
altstadt mit dem outlet charakter um
eben eine lebendige altstadt zu haben
ist so schwer getroffen dass es einem
wirklich die sprache verschlägt
und deshalb ist die hilfe so wichtig und
wir sind hierher gekommen und jetzt eben
auch ein bild zu machen ich möchte allen
helfern danken den institutionen der thw
der feuerwehr der bundeswehr dem drk
allen ehrenamtlichen den vielen privaten
unternehmen die hergekommen ist in den
vielen spendern und den vielen menschen
die anpacken gerade auch die jungen
menschen packen so sehr an dass es gut
zu sehen und das gibt einander kraft
aber es ist auch sehr klar dass wir hier
einen sehr langen atem brauchen werden
und deshalb frau bürgermeisterin unter
landrat wir werden sie nicht nur zum
vergessen sondern wir
immer wieder ein bild darüber machen wie
es mit dem wiederaufbau steht
wir werden morgen im kabinett in berlin
ein programm auflegen wo es um
finanzielle hilfe geht und hier geht es
darum dass auf der einen seite
unbürokratische soforthilfe ausgezahlt
habe gemeinsam mit dem land das land
wird am donnerstag beschließen der
ministerpräsident gesagt und dann werden
wir mit ihnen gemeinsam alles
daransetzen dass das geld schnell zu den
menschen kommt die oft nichts mehr haben
außer das was sie am leibe tragen und
die deshalb auf die unterstützung
angewiesen sind
und dann wird es einen zweiten teil
geben und darüber werden wir auch mit
den ministerpräsidenten aller
bundesländer sprechen es gibt nämlich
auch eine solidarität zwischen den
ländern über einen auch sportler und das
wird eine lange zeit dauern
ich habe heute nochmal mich vom
verkehrsminister bei uns auch
informieren lassen alles was bundes
infrastruktur ist sowohl straßen als
auch schienen da werden die schäden
aufgenommen da wird natürlich auch alles
daran gesetzt dass wir das schnell
wieder herrichten können zb mit
behelfsbrücken denn gerade brücken sind
ja kaputt gegangen also wir werden auch
von bundesseite alles daran setzen und
das in einem guten miteinander mit
ländern und kommunen und kreisen
und ich glaube es zeigt sich an dieser
stelle dass unser land dadurch stark ist
dass wir miteinander haben dass wir
jetzt uns sozusagen zusammentun um diese
schwierige situation hier in der region
und ganz besonders und was mit 24 zu
überwinden
ich möchte ihnen ganz herzlich danken
für die kraft die hier so viele menschen
auch die mitarbeiter ich habe gerade
eben mitarbeiterinnen von erfolgsband
gesehen die sich jetzt um ganz andere
sachen kümmern jeder tut was er kann und
dafür ein ganz herzliches dankeschön
das ist das was ein land oder
nun stark macht und ich wünsche ihnen
allen viel kraft und wir werden
versuchen das unsrige zu tun um schritt
für schritt voranzukommen